it ran on the 21st of august it gave
both sides but it's the first time that
on major TV coverage our side has been
covered yeah what's why don't we start
and then we can have questions at the
end well I'm Marjorie Hecht from 21st
century science and technology magazine
and I would like to welcome you to this
open forum on the holes in the ozone
scare the holes in the ozone scare is
the name of a book we published in early
June which refutes the ozone hysteria we
published it in English as you can see
in German German came out a little bit
earlier three or four months earlier and
also in French in German and French
editions they have gotten quite a lot of
major press coverage in Germany and in
France and in fact just in the French
press over the past two days the major
publications like nouvel Observateur and
other newspapers have given reviews of
the book all of the reviews have been
favorable so far of course in this
country there has been very little on
reviewing the book or noticing it
someone will get in the question period
to the author and he can tell you a
little bit more about the debate that
has gone on the way we'll run the forum
I will talk for about 10 minutes and
then the author of the book Rogelio
Maduro we call him Roger will speak for
about 30 minutes and then we will leave
the rest of the time open for questions
from the audience
now we published this book the holes in
the ozone scare because we want to
overturn the Montreal Protocol this is
the 1987 agreement that the u.s. signed
along with many other countries that
would phase out the use of
chlorofluorocarbons CFCs now why do we
want to overturn the Montreal Protocol
first because the phase-out of CFCs will
kill people this is not something you
ordinarily hear in the press they tell
you how you're going to get die of skin
cancer from increased ultraviolet but
the actual fact is that if we phase out
CFCs and freon and make them more
expensive the replacements more
expensive people are going to die here
and and in the third world especially
this is calculable we have calculated it
you can see that in the book the second
reason that we're over determined to
overturn the Montreal Protocol is
because there's no scientific evidence
for banning CFCs just ideology
speculation and computer models that
bear no relationship to reality finally
we've determined to overturn the
Montreal Protocol because we're
concerned with really saving this planet
and preserving its most important
resource and it's only creative resource
which is mankind the ozone hole scare
like the other issues you heard of at
the Earth Summit that took place in Rio
de Janeiro in June is really about
population it's about a war on
population oh now already there are many
casualties in this war mostly in the
developing sector and mostly people of
color we define every individual as
being sacred as having the potential for
creativity of being capable of reason of
using science and technology to solve
any new problem that comes up and to
create new resources that is our
perspective as
21st century magazine who are our
opponents well on the other side is a
growing irrational movement based on
fear and superstition a movement that
defines a human being and you can read
this definition in this year's
environmental almanac which is put out
by the World Resources Institute they
define a human being as someone who
produces 3/4 of a ton of solid waste per
year you can see the difference of
approach here the Montreal Protocol was
several years in the making
from the first ozone depletion article
which Rodger Maduro will tell you about
until 1987 and it was not only it was
not something that occurred
spontaneously this is something that
took several millions of dollars of
funding to get signed to get organ to
organize those countries to sign it
these millions of dollars flow to the
environmental groups for the specific
purpose of developing the ozone scare
story just to take one small example of
these millions we can look at the World
Resources Institute which is based here
in Washington and see the money that
they have received in the past five
years in 1986 and this comes from the
foundation directory which publishes the
amounts of grants that groups nonprofit
groups receive they received $10,000
quote to brief European nongovernmental
organizations on stratospheric ozone
depletion in 1987 they got $800,000 this
is from the andrew mellon foundation
toward a project on greenhouse warming
and ozone depletion in 87 and 88 they
got another fifty thousand dollars each
year from the Charles Stewart Mott
Foundation with the objective of quote
to advance scientific understanding and
policy implications on atmospheric
changes with potentially major
environmental impact depletion of
atmospheric ozone
they got another hundred thousand
dollars in 1988 again for a project
quote to further international efforts
to protect the stratospheric ozone layer
during this period they had another
twenty five million dollar grant as an
environment and endowment fund so you
can see that this is just one group and
the money one environmentalist group has
received to promote the ozone scare now
the Montreal Protocol is viewed as very
important by the environmentalist
community they see it as a model for
other global Accords because it has it
has some teeth in it this is something
they brag about for example in the book
the sequel to the limits of growth book
they have a whole chapter on ozone
bragging how this is the first time that
the nations of the world agreed to ban a
useful substance quote before it had
produced any measurable damage to human
health or the economy so you can see why
this is a very important treaty for us
to overturn now as an organization
twenty-first century science and
technology does not have millions of
dollars the way the environmentalists do
but we have a very important weapon a
very powerful weapon called the truth we
are challenging the press
scientists representatives of scientific
groups such as people here to discover
this truth for yourselves investigate
find out report on the other side on
what is never heard in the daily press
that there are many scientists in this
country who do not agree that there is
an ozone crisis who do not believe the
ozone scare because the research they
have done tells them that there is no
ozone crisis I would also ask people
here to ask proponents of the ozone
scare whether they think there are too
many people in the world this is a very
basic question I've never had a no
answer to this question when I've
of a representative of an
environmentalist group I also asked them
how do they intend to get rid of the
surplus that they see in the world you
can ask this question of Richard
Benedict Richard Benedict built the
Montreal Protocol and then he wrote a
book about it who is he well he was four
years the head of the US State
Department's office of population before
he moved into organizing the Montreal
Protocol
you can ask Sherwood Rowland now this is
a name some of you may not be familiar
with he is now the president of the
American Association for the Advancement
of science he is the one who developed
the ozone theory back in nineteen the
ozone depletion theory 1974 and Roger
Maduro the author of this book will be
talking about him ask him what he thinks
about our estimates and the
refrigeration industry estimates that 30
to 40 million people will die as a
result of the ban on CFCs not only is he
the president of the triple-a s the
American Association for the Advancement
of science he also is a signer of
something called the Morelia declaration
this was published in the New York Times
twice as a 1/3 page ad in October of
last year
I'll read the last paragraph of this
declaration which had about 30 other
signers with Rowland Rowland's name
being the second because it will give
you an idea of the philosophy of the
people behind the ozone depletion fraud
this paragraph says quote if the latter
half of the 20th century has been marked
by human liberation movements the final
decade of the second millennium will be
characterized by liberation movements
among species so that one day we can
attain genuine equality among all living
things so I propose that people here ask
dr. Roland if the CFC ban that will kill
millions of people
represents what he calls genuine
equality among
all living things this is the challenge
that we have posed with the publication
of this book the holes in the ozone
scare we price the book at $15 so that
it could become a popular book we have
sent it to the press around the country
we want people to read it we think that
people will be wonderfully relieved to
know that there is no ozone crisis which
is what Roger Maduro the author of this
book will be talking about now and Roger
I think if you speak for about 30
minutes
35 minutes and then we'll take questions
from the audience I also want to mention
that all the reviews of this book that
have appeared in Europe and the few in
the scientific press in the United
States have all been favorable I'm sure
there are people in who would like to
criticize the book no one has done so in
the US press the review in Businessweek
in the German language Businessweek
which I'll pass around after the Roger
speaks is really a very prominent review
it appeared in a very large publication
in Germany and the publisher himself
wrote a book review saying this is a
great book essentially so this is Roger
Maduro
so the they don't start
okay I'm gonna I will try to keep my
remarks short because I really would
like to get some questions from the
audience there is a lot of questions to
be answered there's a lot of issues that
have to be raised and the you can read
the book you'll get a lot of the details
in there I can't go over all the
materials I'm going to touch in a few
minutes over the main points in terms of
what the scientific evidence is refuting
the ozone depletion theory what I would
like to say from the outset is that
every single tenant of this theory is a
fraud well actually you can't say about
the theory a theory is a theory but
you've got a scare where supposedly the
the we're going to get fried by
ultraviolet radiation unless we've been
chlorofluorocarbons and I would like to
start by picking up on what March
mentioned before is the question to
start with from a reality standpoint
what will the consequences of banning
CFCs on the world on the world
population and experts in the
refrigeration industry have estimated
that between twenty and thirty million
people are going to die every single
year starting around the year 2000 and
they will increase as the decade goes
along but that that's about the year
2000 because of the ban on CFCs and you
don't need to go very far to see what
the consequences of such a ban is all
you have to do is look at southern
Florida you got here King Andrew just
came by and he it smashed and destroyed
most of southern Florida now what is it
that the press is showing well people
don't have refrigerators anymore
what does that mean they have no food
they can't keep their food cold it's
oils so they're running around looking
for food and this is what the ban on
CFCs is going to do is going to collapse
the entire world
refrigeration chain by which food is
transported 75% of the food that
Americans eat today is refrigerated at
one point or another that whole chain is
going to collapse so if you want to get
a picture of what the actual
consequences of banning CFCs are
look at the level of hunger in Florida
today and that will give you an idea of
what we're confronting now in terms of
the theory itself but the way I got
started into this in actually writing
the book I first wrote a whole series of
articles going back in 1988 I was doing
an article on global warming and I
interviewed Reed Bryson from the
University of Wisconsin one of the
world's leading experts on global
warming climate change and I we were
talking about global warming and
suddenly he pops up the whole issue of
ozone depletion I don't know how I came
up in the conversation and he mentions
to me well there is a volcano in
Antarctica that puts out more chlorine
into the atmosphere every day that the
entire amount of chlorine from CFCs and
I was pretty shocked and my background
is as a geologist and I know about
volcanoes and I never thought well
chlorine comes out from volcanoes is not
something anybody thinks and the whole
point about this is that the theory is
based on the idea that
chlorofluorocarbons rise into the
stratosphere where they meet ultraviolet
radiation which breaks them up and
freeze the chlorine molecule now CFCs do
absolutely nothing to ozone it is this
chlorine molecule that's our atoms that
supposedly goes around like a little
pac-man creature eating up ozone
molecules and breaking them up and
causing all the damage now nobody ever
mentions in this theory or any of these
proponents of ozone depletion that there
are natural sources of chlorine they
just don't access according to the
theory according to the they simply
ignore their existence and we see the
first transparency here well let's
actually compare the amount of chlorine
from natural sources versus CFCs here
you've got seawater contributes an
estimated 600 million tons of chlorine
into the atmosphere every year volcanoes
contribute 36 million tons of chlorine
into the atmosphere and this is in years
with no great volcanic eruptions and
definitely not like when Mount Pinatubo
erupts they serve tranquil years then
you've got 8.4 million times
biomass burning five million tons from
ocean bacteria ocean biota and then you
have the 750,000 tonnes contained in
chlorine the chlorine contained in CFCs
and the theory alleges that 1% of this
chlorine approximately is released every
year by the breakdown of CFCs therefore
you have an estimated somewhere around
7,500 tons of chlorine are supposedly
being released by the breakdown of CFCs
so you're comparing 7,500 tons of
chlorine from CFCs to 650 million tonnes
from natural sources of course none of
the proponents of the ozone depletion
theory can ever mention that they are
natural sources of chlorine the whole
theory flat falls flat on his face they
argue well this chlorine does not make
into the stratosphere because there's
water soluble but that is simply not
true they they have not bothered to
actually do the measurements to do the
experiments to indicate that as a matter
of fact they haven't even bothered to do
the experiments to indicate that CFC the
whole reaction that they claimed happens
in the stratosphere happens the the
reaction that leads to ozone depletion
has never by CFCs has never been
observed in the stratosphere has never
been observed in laboratory it is
outrageous it's a theory on paper and on
computer models there is no experimental
evidence to indicate that this happens
anywhere or observational evidence the
next transparency
shows a comparison of natural sources of
bromine which is supposedly an even
worse ozone buster than chlorine
tremendous comparisons there they're
banning halos which are the world's most
effective firefighting chemicals on the
basis of their alleged threat to the
ozone layer again there is no evidence
that this hey loans are making it to the
stratosphere there is no evidence that
any of the bromine in the stratosphere
comes from Halen's
now I bring this up when I made this
table when I made this this chart they
the issue of methyl bromide which is one
of the most ubiquitous fumigants
extremely important in fumigation for
fruits and vegetables is absolutely
critical it's now on the list to be
banned in November in Copenhagen so I
did not that was not an issue when the
book was written so I don't have it here
but I bring it out just so you can get a
comparison the the enormous amounts of
natural bromine now the allegations of
methyl bromide is when is sprayed on
fruits and vegetables it still manages
to get to the stratosphere and deplete
ozone now you look at this and again all
this natural bromine does not make it to
the stratosphere allegedly it doesn't
excess now again you're running into
problems what this theory is completely
inconsistent I'd like to get the Thanks
now going from comparing natural sources
of chlorine versus versus man-made let's
go and look at the actual issues of
whether there is also in the pollution
or not and it gets extremely interesting
in the process of writing the book I
interviewed a very large number of
scientists and many of them were very
adamant about claims that the proponents
of the ozone depletion theory were
falsifying the data to indicate that
there is ozone depletion when there
actually isn't any ozone depletion going
on and this is one of the most
interesting charts of one comes across
what you see in here is on the top is
the concentrations global ozone levels
starting around 1958 when you have a
world well you set a worldwide network
of dots and instruments measuring ozone
concentrations will set out and below
you have a number of sunspots see so a
number of sunspots and the interesting
thing is how closely both charts follow
each other and what scientists point out
is sunspot numbers solar radiation is
the major determinate of concentration
as well so when there's more solar
radiation there is more ozone because
you have more intense ultraviolet
radiation to break up oxygen molecules
and turn them into ozone molecules to
break them out and they when they
recombine to become ozone at the same
time the ultraviolet radiation also
breaks down the ozone molecules and
recombines them back into either oxygen
or into ozone so it's a process that is
constantly going on that there's this
whole belief that the media spreads and
and even people like Albert Gore believe
Gore believes that ozone is a
non-renewable resource which is just
complete nonsense there is it's even
stated in the clean air bill the clean
air bill the section and also on banning
CFCs in the United States states
explicitly ozone the ozone layers a
non-renewable resource you get billions
of tons of ozone are created every
second and are destroyed every second
it's a constant process and it is done
by solar radiation by ultraviolet
radiation so it's a very close match it
was very interesting anyway
God is an 11-year solar cycle on a 22
year solar cycle now what did this
intrepid rigorous scientist from the
ozone trance panel ought to say the
world do well they went off and they
started taking their measurements that
they take they took today of the
measurement success and they started
they picked 1969's they're starting here
and they pick 1986 as they're ending
here which is very curious because they
could have started back to 58 or 62 or
64 but no they picked 69 which as you
can notice is is the top of the cycle
the greatest concentration of ozone was
found in 1969 1970 and whether they pick
us they're ending point
they picked 1986 which is a bottom of
the cycle so of course you're gonna get
ozone depletion it's just entirely an
artifact of what they depict you could
show a thickening of the ozone layers
and argue it by CFCs by picking the
actual historical ozone minimum which is
1962 and projecting that 17 years later
which is what they did it took 17 years
which is one and-a-half solar cycles and
you end up at the top of the cycle and
so so what you get is the thickening of
the ozone layer it's phony this whole
thing is phony many scientists have
actually documented that there has been
no change in the you cannot
statistically see any change at all in
the thickness of the ozone layer over
the past 30 years and that's what the
actual evidence what the actual
observations indicate let's go to the
next
this next transparency gets to another
one of the points
there is no question CFCs do make it to
the stratosphere you get here into
another extremely interesting point
which is our CFC sites will be broken
down by ultraviolet radiation or not I
mean why is it that if ultraviolet
radiation reaches the surface of the
earth that the CFCs are not actually
breaking down let's say in Los Angeles
would be which should be a very positive
thing because then the chlorine could go
around and and get rid of all the ozone
pollution in Los Angeles well because
you have to get certain very specific
wavelengths of ultraviolet before the
ozone be preserved before the CFCs
can be broken down and the one looks at
this chart and you see there's a very
rapid decline it's a logarithmic scale
so you see a very very rapid decline in
the concentrations of CFCs as you get
into the stratosphere the stratosphere
is approximately rapid decline of the
concentrations of CFCs now this is one
of the proves that the ozone depletion
theory is supposed to correct because
CFCs are breaking down the chlorine has
been released and that's what
demonstrates now that they have a
problem that the wavelengths of
ultraviolet radiation that can break
down CFCs which do exist don't reach
below basically 30 kilometers altitude
and if you want to find them in any
concentration you have to get up about
40 45 50 kilometers altitude and what
you're seeing here is that the CFCs are
not getting up that high in the
stratosphere so they're actually not
encountering the wavelengths of
ultraviolet that can break them down so
there's something else going on and what
physical atmospheric scientists point
out is they're simply been recycled back
into the troposphere they get to the
stratosphere which the entirety of the
stratosphere is essentially an inversion
layer just like you have on top of Los
Angeles is warming air on top so the air
is trapped and goes back down so what
you have is see CFCs are getting up to
the stratosphere and they're coming back
down as I said nobody has ever observed
the CFC breaking down in the
stratosphere
in athlean-x but before we get to that
one I only have a few transparencies
there is that there's a lot more charts
and tables in the book what I wanted to
mention now is what does actually happen
to CFCs on the interesting thing there's
a lot of research going on in this by
experts on bioremediation people that
studied how bacteria can destroy
different chemicals break them down and
what they have discovered is that
there's families of bacteria that think
of CFCs as food and there is evidence
laboratory observational experimental
evidence indicating that what's
happening to CFCs is that they're being
destroyed in anoxic soils in swamps and
other places by this bacteria that break
down the chlorine atoms from the CFCs
and use them instead of oxygen for
respiration and the evidence is very
clear that that is going on there is
also evidence that there is other sinks
for CFCs in the troposphere which the
theory claims don't exist and this sinks
include deposition in the soils includes
breaking down in the soils includes
absorption by plant lipoproteins it
includes absorption and destruction in
the oceans where you have a lot of this
bacteria that use that consume chlorine
and bromine for the same way just as
certain types of soil bacteria do and so
on and so forth so the small amount of
CFCs that disappear every year can be
accounted by their destruction by other
processes by sinks by sinks in the
troposphere so one doesn't have to go to
the stratosphere to find a sink for CFCs
now what is the threat well supposedly
the ozone layer is going to be depleted
and we're all going to get ultraviolet
radiation and we're all gonna fry now
what what is never mentioned in this
theory is the fact that ultraviolet
radiation increases as one gets closer
to the equator as a matter of fact from
the poles to the equator there's a 5,000
percent increase in ultraviolet
radiation that is the equivalent of
moving that you get a
person increase in multiple irradiation
by moving six miles closer to the
equator so the threat from the ozone
depletion theory said you're going to
have a five to ten percent ozone
depletion which is the equivalent of a
ten to twenty percent increase in
ultraviolet radiation which in the real
world is the equivalent of moving 60 to
120 miles south when you form where you
presently live now if somebody were to
mention this suddenly people would say
well what's the threat and all these
people moved to Florida the threat was
not ultraviolet radiation it was
Hurricane Andrew as a matter of fact
people that moved to Florida older
people live on the average ten years
longer than those that stay in northern
latitudes that's why people moved to
Arizona and New Mexico and Florida and
Texas uh-huh they like the Sun now this
transparency here indicates part of the
reason you have such high rates of
cancer in Australia Australia is much
closer to the equator and there's also
less ozone so you have more ultraviolet
radiation and compare that to
Philadelphia a tremendous amount more
ultraviolet radiation than when you get
in northern latitudes and that and that
is why people that have white skin that
come from Ireland in England when they
move to Australia yes they're gonna have
higher incidence of skin cancer now when
we talk about skin cancer let's get back
to this whole scare more people are
gonna get skin cancer this is such a
threat what about 600,000 people get
skin cancer in the United States what
it's never standard is that the vast
majority of the skin cancers are benign
skin cancers they don't kill people 99
percent well basal cell carcinoma which
is the most abundant type of skin cancer
are not malignant a squamous cell that's
500,000 cases 100,000 cases are squamous
cell carcinoma and about 2,500 people
die from that every year again those
that the two that are related to
exposure to ultraviolet radiation now
malignant melanoma is the one that kills
the most people six to seven thousand
people every year in the United States
yet only 28 29
in cases per year and there is no direct
evidence linking malignant melanoma to
ultraviolet radiation as a matter of
fact the evidence points out that people
that get malignant melanoma people spend
too much time in the office and if they
get Sun they get it by going out for a
whole weekend or whole weekend and
frying themselves or spending times
unter on their Sun lamps which actually
produce mostly ultraviolet a radiation
not ultraviolet B so you've got a lot of
problems with the actual threat but I
would like to get to the basic point of
what's the threat you move six to 220
miles south I mean how dangerous is that
this whole idea of cataracts among sheep
that was exposed to the fraud by kgo-tv
in San Francisco about three four months
ago they did a whole special program
they sent the whole team down to
Patagonia to film all this blind sheep
that Senator Albert Gore speaks so much
about in all his hearings about ozone
depletion and what they found out about
the Holy Land sheep is that they didn't
have cataracts they had a bacterial
infection which made him blind see
nobody had actually bothered to see
whether it was cataracts or not yes
there's blind sheep but then it's not
cataracts there's nothing to do with the
ozone hole um can I
this is my last one I've left a lot of
things out and we can bring it up in the
question and answer section actually
there's one more after this and here you
have the Antarctic ozone hole it was
very interesting we'll get to this in a
minute I like to point out the entire
league ozone hole was not discovered in
1985 by Joseph Foreman what is today
known as the Antarctica's ozone hole was
discovered in 1982 by Shigeru chubachi
a Japanese scientist and what he noticed
was an increase in what's called a
Southern anomaly which is what which is
what the ozone hole used to be known as
back in 1956 through 58 a team of
British researchers led by Gordon
Thompson discovered a very interesting
anomaly in Antarctica in which the
concentrations of ozone went became very
very low and suddenly at inrun
october/november there was a very great
jumping concentrations and it went back
to what they expected as normal and they
called it an anomaly in 58 and on the
other side of Antarctica a French
scientific team measured the lowest
concentrations of ozone that have ever
been measured including recent
measurements so this is a natural
phenomena now and what I'd like to it's
clear the ozone holes a natural
phenomenon is is connected to a series
of dynamic chemical processes and
perhaps processes that come from space
come from solar influences and space
influences which is why I left this this
is the international space Congress and
what I think scientists should start
looking at is what are the interactions
between the solar wind solar radiation
the magnetosphere and the Earth's
atmosphere and you get something
extremely interesting what happens when
ozone is depleted which actually occurs
in Antarctica for a period about four to
six weeks of the year so you get a very
intense vortex surrounding Antarctica
that basically seals all the ozone rich
air that's coming from the tropics where
ozone is produce and it keeps it outside
Antarctica and inside Antarctica you get
a cauldron of very rapid very
fascinating chemical reactions where
ozone is depleted now but all you ever
hear about is OH
depletion but if you look at what
actually happens inside this vortex
normally do you get ozone depletion you
get a nitrogen oxide depletion you get a
nitrogen oxide hole you get the
atmospheric is called becomes very dry
there's very little humidity because the
water vapor almost disappears again you
could call a water vapor hole I like the
nitrogen oxide hole because supposedly
that's the Earth's immune system but
nobody gets you can't whip up his theory
around a nitrogen oxide hole people
don't quite get too excited about that
so they talk about the ozone hole but
what about all these other things going
on right nobody ever mentions that and
and I would like to end with this last
thing is why are scientists one is why
the environmental is pushing this this
this tremendous scare and it has to do
with many things but I think one of the
principal wants is is money you got a
bunch of scientists that's only
discovered or so-called scientists that
you can make a lot of money become very
famous and very powerful even assume the
presidency of the American Association
for the Advancement of science by
pushing scientific frauds and you have
environmental groups which combined are
making in excess of eight to nine
billion dollars a year entirely based on
scare stories so they push the scare
stories as a fundraising gimmick and
they have to constantly go from one to
the next one they're recycled the same
scientists that we're pushing nuclear
winter and we're pushing global cooling
and we're then pushing global warming
are now pushing all zone depletion and
go from one scare to the next one and
and and depress and people have a very
short memory and they forget what the
previous scare was they just remember
the latest one and we have to change
that because there are very real issues
that have to be addressed in the world
today the whole entire last chapter of
the book is dealing with the issue of
how do you feed mankind how do you
elevate mankind from the status of
tremendous crushing poverty that you see
today from conditions that lead to war
because of lack of resources as your
seeing in Eastern Europe today and and
that is what we should be focusing our
energies are the money's because how do
we resolve our the problems that face
the world today thank you Thank You
Roger before we go to questions I just
wanted to say something about blind
sheep and Albert Gore because I think
the real problem is the blind sheep in
the nation who believe these scares who
fall for every scare and that's really
what we want to combat with this book
the holes in the ozone scare this book
has a chapter reprinted from Gordon
Dobson's original work on ozone 1968
we've reprinted his chapter from the
exploring the atmosphere it also has a
preface by one of the world-famous
volcanologist Harun Tao CF who works out
of France I want to change the name tag
here but I don't see I don't see my own
so yeah so I would urge people to buy
the book it is $15 it's available from
us at 21st century science and
technology magazine in Washington DC and
it's available here at $15 our address
is p.o box one six two eight five
washington DC - zero zero four one and
that that is really what we want to do
we want to end blind sheep ism in the
United States so another thing people
could do is ask your bookstores for the
book ask your newspapers to review it
let's let's get it out we will also
debate any scientists anywhere really if
if anyone wants to set up a scientific
debate we're open to it we have
challenged the other side to debate we
challenge the Association what is it the
Association for a responsible CFC policy
we think they're a little bit
irresponsible but we intend to press for
a debate
with them coming up at their big meeting
at the end of this month now let's go to
some questions questions from anyone he
said well I'll still ask him that he
came up with these figures about the
number of populations dying you referred
to southern Florida but what happened in
southern Florida wasn't just you know
the refrigerators I mean houses and
everything was destroyed how do you you
know how do you make the comparison and
that so many people are going to die as
a result of banning CFCs the reason I
mentioned Florida is you have all those
food lines because the electricity was
cut off and the refrigerators were
destroyed so so you have no way of
storing food so the food that people
have spoiled and you can't keep food for
a long time and you see there's very
long lines of people waiting for ice and
those are the conditions well you won't
have houses destroyed the houses are not
going to be pummeled down to the earth
but you will have the same conditions
people will not have a place to store
their food so that it last people will
not have access to fresh food and that's
the whole point that I was making under
was a very dramatic example of what
happens when you when you cut off
electricity what happens when you cut
off refrigeration and it continues to be
a dramatic example and I think it's
going to be for a while because the the
US government I mean they respond
immediately whenever there is an
environmental scare you have an
immediate response they pour billions
and billions of dollars to respond to
environmental threats when when you get
a real threat as an do when you get the
kind of massive destruction that you
have seen in Florida and Louisiana the
response is very slow and they've
written niggardly
they don't want to spend any money very
cheap and it's outrageous we should look
at this and say why it is that all this
spotted owls all these little turtles
out in the desert can get such vast
amounts of government resources so it's
vast amounts of money when human beings
that are really in truly suffering
get help it takes almost a whole week
for the president to reactance and help
I mean what is it in the mind of the
establishment that animals are so much
more important than human beings and I
think it's one of the fundamental
questions that we have to ask ourselves
what has happened to this country yes
if the CFC is being broken up or if I
guess if that is not happening in a
stratosphere how does one account for
the increase in chlorine concentration
in the stratosphere over the past
several years I don't think you can say
there has been a chlorine concentration
in the stratosphere they have absolutely
no idea how much chlorine there is in
the stratosphere none they you have a
problem these people make claims like
that they don't have the data to back it
up so you look at chlorine I mean what
what we know that is a fact is the
concentrations of chlorine in the
stratosphere are very stratified they
change dramatically depending on what
level of the stratosphere you happen to
be in they can change very rapidly
depending to atmospheric conditions
temperature pressure whether you have a
storm system the jet stream going
through they depend very significantly
on the angle of which the Sun is
striking the earth and you can change
concentrations of chlorine in the
stratosphere 50 percent from one hour to
the next so what do you mean that we
know what concentrations of chlorine we
have in the stratosphere second of all
most species of chlorine are not even
measured when they measure for chlorine
they measure only two to three species
of chlorine so they don't actually know
what the vast majority of species of
chlorine concentrations in the
stratosphere are and furthermore do you
have consistent readings no you read it
by sending a plane up there and taking
some readings and sending it down you
don't have a daily hourly
minute-by-minute reading of chlorine
concentrations for any period of time in
this trance fear and whenever they take
the readings they take them at different
places of the world that there is no
consistency nobody can come up and say
we know how much chlorine is in the
start
fear it's a fraud it's a lie anybody who
says we know is a liar and and that's
its plain and simple yes further
questions did you have one yes it's
always reported though that there are
four CFCs that people won't have to
throw out their refrigerators because
chemical companies are making chemicals
that you'll be able to put in your
refrigerator they're having a lot of fun
with these replacements right now
no they're discovering this the real
duds and it's kind of enjoyable we're
not quite enjoyable because it's a real
tragedy but it's very amusing to
actually look at the complete hysteria
and trade publications right now
regarding this this replacements I mean
what are they discovering in the auto
industry they thought great we've got
the DuPont Corporation is making this
replacement that it's going to go into
all the refrigerator's of cars that
supposedly will be built after 1995 so
many 1993 well what are you finding
those replacements are toxic they break
down the internal components of the
compressors so refrigerators and air
conditioners that are being built with
this replace replacements will last
somewhere between three to seven years
instead of 18 to 20 years for normal
refrigerators and and there in the case
of I guess let's let's go to the issue
of car air conditioners you now have all
this air conditioning shops across the
United States that have they're facing a
massive nightmare they they have to have
a recycling machinist of July first
if you repair car air conditioners you
have to recycle the freon the CFCs in
the car if you don't if you release them
into the air you face one year in jail
per release and 25,000 dollar fine per
kilogram released okay
very stiff fines very stiff threats now
how much does it cost to buy this
recycling machine well anywhere from
fifteen hundred dollars to fifty
thousand dollars depending on what kind
of machine you buy and what you want to
do with it now to get a machine to
recycle freons now the
placement for free us is completely
incompatible with the free onset
existing presently existing air
conditioners for cars so you have to get
recycling machine for free on for
hfc-134a the dupont corporation's Suva
so you have to get a recycling machine
for that on top of which you have to get
an entire new set of tools for that and
you can never mix the tools because you
will destroy the system that you're
working on if you mix the tools that
become contaminated now there's a whole
interesting element to this many
companies have started making
replacements for CFCs that are not Suva
that are a an in-between breed between
freon 12 CFC twelve and Suva now the
thing about this this in between
replacements is that they destroy
systems that have freon 12 in them and
systems that have hfc-134a them okay so
you got to get a recycling machine for
that for those replacements oh you got
to get three recycling machines okay to
begin with and three sets of tools to
repair our conditioners today and if you
make any mistake you will basically
contaminate and destroy every single air
conditioning system that you repair and
it'll go on and it'll take a little
while for you to figure out where the
mistake was made so now you're facing
one year in jail if your recycling
machine breaks down and you have to
repair cars that's you make a living out
of that so what this auto repair shops
are doing refrigeration repair shops
order if air conditioning they have to
buy a spare recycle machine so they've
bought you know they're buying for six
recycling machines is a complete
nightmare ten twenty thirty forty
thousand dollars per shop and you can't
mix or match anything huh and on top of
that well now not to say that they're
suffering monetarily they're gonna make
a tremendous amount of money out of this
and this is part of the problem people
really think that you should go ahead
and and and totally official line on
ozone and CFCs because there is a lot of
money to be made we're talking in the
range of two to three hundred billion
dollars a year in profits because for
giant chemical
corporations like DuPont and all the way
down to little repair shops because of
the balancing a/c so you're talking
about enormous amounts of money and
profits that are to be made just to give
you an idea of the kind of profits we're
talking about two years from now you go
repair your air conditioner car you buy
today let's say it breaks down alright
or it just simply runs out of freon this
gets punctured runs out of freon
something happens not a big repair these
days it could could have cost twenty
thirty dollars a year ago well in
1995-96 it'll cost you $2,000 to fix
that because you will no longer be able
to just put friend in there you're gonna
have to tear up the entire air
conditioning system and replace the
whole thing with a unit that uses
hfc-134a well it that's gonna cost you a
pretty penny but it's also gonna make
somebody a very nice profit and and and
this is just the tip of the iceberg in
terms of the replacements the
replacements for phone blowing uses and
CFCs are now banned in Europe because
they discovered they had a nasty thing
of becoming highly toxic and killing
people they can kill people when they
are heated up so they banned them in
Europe
now the DuPont corporation doesn't want
to ban them they want to continue using
them that's the whole issue we have to
raise well what is actually going on in
here that we're allowing toxic chemicals
potentially carcinogenic to be used on a
daily basis replacing chemicals that
were completely harmless where where are
our non-toxic non-flammable not are not
cancer-causing so on and so forth I mean
there are ideal chemicals to use in
refrigeration so there is a tremendous
amount of problems with these
replacements and and we'll start to see
more and more as time goes by there
really is no ideal replacements for CFCs
I see that maybe 10 to 20 years from now
we'll have entire new technologies that
can replace CFCs but not in the
immediate term yes so what's gonna
happen when when people start to
understand that that they're being
defrauded and that that they're having
to pay two thousand dollars to replace
their air conditioning system their car
what's going to happen when people
suddenly understand they've been taken
what's gonna happen then well the
strategy on this and and this is pretty
the strategy of this this body called
the Alliance for responsible CFC policy
which is which is an organization that
represents the DuPont corporation and
other former producers producers and
former producers of CFCs who are
actually pushing very hard to have CFCs
ban so they can produce this alternative
chemicals I forgot to mention the
replacements for CFCs DuPont Suva is is
30 to 40 times more expensive than freon
12 now so there is bodies promoting this
now what's going to happen is a very
interesting question I think people are
gonna get very very angry and you're
going to see an explosion in this
country the whole strategy until this
point for the Alliance and the
environmental groups has been let's pass
this band let's do it as quickly as
possible so that people don't even have
time to think of what hit them
and then it will be too late to reverse
the policies of the Montreal Protocol
and the problem they're dealing with is
a problem of reality the replacements
don't work they're extremely expensive
and the economy is collapsing the United
States is facing a very profound
depression it is not a recession it is a
real depression and people just simply
do not have the money to continue paying
thousands of dollars for environmental
per family per year for environmental
legislation that does absolutely no good
for them and that does not save the
environment or reduce pollution and and
I see a very strong reaction even
possibly just within the next few months
and I think one of the things that will
trigger it is the ban on methyl bromide
because that has an immediate
consequence by banning methyl bromide
you will be destroying essentially the
food and vegetable industries of many
countries of the world including the
United States the the estimates are I
mean basically you won't be able every
single fruit and vegetable that is
imported into the United States is
fumigated before it can come in oh if
you don't have Bethel bromide you can
forget about importing fruits and
vegetables you know the very severe
shortages of fruits and vegetables
American farmers also use it to protect
the fruits and vegetables from all kinds
of of nematodes and other kinds of bugs
that can produce all kinds of serious
ill effects on people
and it is not toxic not congenic it's a
fine thing to use but that is gonna have
an immediate reaction if that is banned
you will see a very very rapid reaction
to this Montreal Protocol to the banning
of CFCs we do think it is possible to
overturn the Montreal Protocol that's
why we have published this book without
millions of dollars behind us as the
environmentalist have we've given a
press conference on it and we are trying
to promote a debate in this country and
get the truth to people around the
country I think it's useful to remind
people if you don't know of the DDT hoax
in 1972 because that was really the
mother of the present ozone scare hoax
DDT was banned in 1972 not because there
was anything wrong with DDT a scientific
panel met for 7 months this was
sponsored by the Environmental
Protection Agency with a Hearing
Examiner and heard 9,000 pages worth of
testimony on the scientific evidence for
and against CF DDT this Hearing Examiner
at the end of seven months ruled that
DDT should not be banned it was saving
millions of lives that it probably saved
more lives than anything any other
man-made chemical invented and yet the
administrator of the EPA at the time
Williams ruckus house within two months
of the hearing examiner's decision of
his own hearing the EPA's here at
scientific hearings decided to ban it
for political reasons that was the first
such ban millions of people have died as
a result you can count those people this
is not something we're making up it's
not exaggerated and I think every hoax
since then has followed the same kind of
pattern you scare people you put out
information that's phony you measure as
one of the scientists did one of the
scientists leading the global warming
fraud today was involved in DDT saying
that it's it collects in the ocean well
where did he measure DDT collecting in
the ocean just happened to be at the
site where the DDT
dump truck washed out then he measured
it again it collects in the soil where
did he measure it well it was on the
runway where the spray plane calibrated
its equipment wasn't a forest it was in
the middle it was in a runway now this
this is the kind of shoddy science that
was publicized by the same environmental
groups they made their name and their
fortunes in the 70s on the DDT hoax this
is a repeat this is we call DDT the
mother of these hoaxes in our magazine
the current issue of 21st century
magazine has a whole story on Rachel
Carson's book Silent Spring and it goes
through page by page showing how she
lied documenting that she would report
you know 20 dogs died from eating DDT
when actually nothing of the sort
happened the scientist who wrote it was
an environmentalist
he called himself an ecologist and he
went back and documented page by page
because he couldn't because he was so
upset when he came to things that he
knew weren't true that were in Rachel
Carson's book and I think that's what
we're seeing today over over the past 20
years Americans have been conditioned to
be blind sheep on environmental issues
they don't know they operate from the
basis of scientific ignorance and really
that's what we're combating we want to
educate people to tell them that you
don't have to be frightened of the ozone
hole in ultraviolet you know to give
them some basis on which to judge the
issue for themselves and that's why
we're holding this forum as well so I
would invite some of the people who look
still a little skeptical to ask
questions we're happy to answer
questions yes sir forgive me if you've
already addressed this I came in a
little late not used to metro systems
and such can you comment on the relative
amount of money you've been throwing
around billions of dollars numbers being
spent in the U in the US or even
worldwide today to a measure whether or
not UV radiation is actually increasing
on the Earth's surface and B determine
what health effects it has on either
plants or people UV light that is
I don't know the exact amounts but it's
not very much and and it is quite
outrageous because that's the threat
how much is ultraviolet radiation
increasing or decreasing and it's a very
good question I'm glad you asked it
because I wasn't able to address this
the actual concentration of ultraviolet
radiation is going down that's there was
a paper in 1980 I 88 that appeared in
science magazine by Joseph Scott Oh of
the National Cancer Institute's
biostatistics branch and what they they
had they have stations operating
starting in 1974 when the whole scare
got going measuring ultraviolet
radiation at eight sites across the
United States and what they found is
that the concentration of UV was going
down now shortly after this paper was
was published half of the stations were
shut down because of quote-unquote
budget cuts which is very interesting
thing and it's amazing because this is
what the threat is which there should be
measurements there has been several
meetings where discussions have been
held about increasing and expanding the
networks measuring ultraviolet radiation
so money is starting to come for it
curiously not from NOAA but from the
Department of Agriculture in other
places to set up measuring networks but
basically globally every all the
evidence indicates that ultraviolet
radiation is either not changing or it's
decreasing which is exactly the opposite
of what should be happening if ozone
depletion was actually occurring so in
terms of actual money it is not a lot I
don't have exact amounts but I know that
it is increasing and it is a very good
thing because I think that's one of the
fundamental things that has to be done
the Americans are why is that the way
are they a little smarter than we are or
what is it they're a little more
experienced they've had a few hundred
more hundred years to understand a
problem and they see what why Americans
more gullible than in European I think I
think the Europeans are as gullible as
the Americans I think the main
difference is that is the the policies
to ban CFCs have a current law have been
implemented longer in Europe and they're
already seeing the consequences of that
so they're much they're way ahead of the
curve than the United States and that
sense that they have seen the
consequences of the ban that they have
seen that the evidence is not there so
the press in Europe has been much more
open to the book as being like like
marchek said the book has been reviewed
by quite a few publications very
prominent publications in Europe
including Germany's version of
Businessweek and one of the leading
newspapers in Switzerland and she
mentioned several the other ones so so
there has been quite a lot more coverage
there I expect that in the United States
the story is going to break hopefully
very soon there has already been there's
not a lot of coverage of the book in the
press and in the NTV there has been a
tremendous amount of coverage in radio I
have been interviewed by more than 12
stations many of them live interviews
with questions and answers very
interesting I know that several other
individuals including Dickson Lyrae the
former governor of this Washington State
Bob whole snack and air-conditioner who
runs a whole network of air conditioning
repair shops across the United States he
created an organization called the ozone
truth squad has been interviewed
probably by now more than 30 radio
stations across the u.s. 50 radio
stations so in the radio has become a
very big hit and I have something like
10 perhaps 10 or 12 radio interviews and
the process of being set up right now
for the next couple of weeks so it's
it's a very hot issue in radio
yes any further questions someone just
asked me out at the side how to order
the book in French if you write to us we
can tell you how to order the book in
French you have to pay in francs and you
can reach us 21st century science and
technology magazine at p.o box one six
two eight five Washington DC 200 four
one
we have the book in English in French
and in German we can tell you how to get
it in German so I want to thank everyone
for coming to this forum again we heard
Roger Maduro the author of the holes in
the ozone scare which is published by
21st century and we thank you for coming
there were copies of the book available
at the back of the room for people
we don't take charts you can write